mais mes chers collègues me permettraz
tout d'abord de vous saluer toutes et
tous et de vous présenter mes mes
meilleurs vœux pour cette nouvelle année
2024 et de vous remercier de votre
présence monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques mes chers collègues la
commission d'aménagement du territoire
et du développement durable et la
commission des affaires économiques sont
réunies conjointement ce matin pour deux
auditions consacrées au projet de loi
relatif à l'organisation organisation de
la gouvernance de la sûreté nucléaire et
de la radioprotection pour répondre au
défis de la relance de la filière
nucléaire et au projet de loi organique
associé nous entendrons successivement
les représentants des deux acteurs
directement concerné par la réforme le
président de l'Autorité de de sûreté
nucléaire que je salue Bernard dorozuk
et le directeur général de l'Institut de
la radioprotection de la Sûreté
Nucléaire Jean-Christophe Niel je vous
rappelle que la commission des affaires
économiques saisie pour avis se réunira
pour examiner le texte 30 janvier le
projet de loi et le projet de loi
organique seront ensuite examinés
ensemble en commission de l'aménagement
du territoire et du développement
durable le mercredi 31 janvier puis en
séance publ le mercredi 7 et le jeudi 8
février un vote solennel sur l'ensemble
des deux textes est prévu le mardi 13
février prochain Pascal Martin a été
désigné rapporteur par la commission
d'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable et Patrick cha
rapporteur pour avis par la commission
des affaires économiques les auditions
des rapporteurs ont commencé dès le
début du mois de janvier vous avez déjà
eu l'opportunité de vous exprimer dans
ce format monsieur dorzuk mais il nous a
semblé essentiel que vous puissiez
également nous présenter votre point de
vue en plinière devant les commissaires
de nos deux commissions et l'ensemble
des groupes représentés il y a près d'un
an la fusion entre l'ASN et l'IRSN avait
été proposé par le gouvernement dans le
cadre de l'examen du projet de loi
accélération nucléaire à l'Assemblée
nationale nous avions été nombreux au
Sénat à déplorer la méthode employée par
le gouvernement que la président prima à
l'avoir qualifié d'insupportable pour
cause cette proposition n'avait fait
l'objet d'aucune concertation ni
d'aucune évaluation et n'avait pas été
soumise à la première assemblée saisie
le Sénat à cet égard il est heureux que
la proposition du gouvernement a
finalement été rejetée par les députés
malmené le Parlement a réagi par le
biais d'une saisine de l'Office
Parlementaire des choix scientifiques et
technologiques leopex par la commission
des affaires économiques du Sénat
euh initiative que je souhaite à nouveau
saluer le rapport de l'OPEX de Stéphane
piennoir et Jean-Luc fugi est paru en
juillet dernier ses conclusions ont
alimenté le projet de fusion par le
gouvernement dont nous sommes
aujourd'hui saisis avant de céder la
parole à la présidente Dominique
estrosissasson j'aimerais partager
l'état d'esprit qui est le mien à
l'amorce de ce chantier législatif sans
entrer à ce stade dans les
considérations de fond concernant
l'opportunité de la réforme notre
priorité et je le dis en tant que
président de la commission en charge des
politiques de prévention des risques est
clair nous souhaitons maintenir notre
surté nucléaire à un niveau d'exigence
le plus élevé possible en l'adaptant aux
enjeux de notre décennie et àez l'avenir
l'opportunité de la relance du nucléaire
dans notre pays qui constitue un débat
majeur pour notre nation et qui nous
mobilisera dans le cadre du projet de
loi souveraineté énergétique est une
problématique d'un are ordre ne nous y
trompons pas le texte qui va nous
mobiliser dans les prochaines semaines
ne nous ène pas à nous positionner
pourou contre l'énergie nucléaire il
nous est demandé de réfléchir au cadre
le plus adapté pour nos concitoyens pour
assurer leur sécurité pour protéger la
santé la salubrité
publique la protection de la nature et
l'environnement tout en garantissant un
niveau de transparence satisfaisant vous
l'urez compris il me semble nécessaire
de dissocier les deux sujets même s'ils
sont sont liés un système de de sûreté
irréprochable une transparence préservée
voire accrue sont des conditions
cineéquanon de l'acceptabilité sociale
du nucléaire sans laquelle la relance de
la filière ne pourra pas se faire je
cède maintenant la parole à ma collègue
Dominique estro Sasson président de la
commission des affaires économiques
avant de vous laisser monsieur DZ nous
partager les premiers éléments dans le
cadre d'un propos liminire madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président donc à mon tour à la suite du
président Lau je souhaite effectivement
vous adresser également mes meilleurs
vœux pour l'année 2024 et souhaiter
puisque nous sommes en audition commune
de NS de de nos deux commissions et bien
que sur des textes nous serions amenés
encore à à travailler ensemble cher
Jean-François bien nous puissions le
faire comme nous allons le faire tout au
long de ce l'examen de ce texte sur la
projet de fusion entre l'ASN et
l'IRSN monsieur le président Monsieur le
Directeur de l'ASN messieurs les
rapporteurs et je salue bien évidemment
Pascal Martin et notre rapporteur pour
la commission des affaires économiques
Patrick chaise mes chers collègues tout
d'abord je tiens à remercier le
président longjau de l'organisation de
ces auditions communes dans le contexte
de la relance de la filière française du
nucléaire la réforme de la gouvernance
de la sûreté nucléaire et de la radio
protection proposée par le gouvernement
peut constituer une opportunité pour
consolider les processus d'expertise
d'instruction d'autorisation et de
contrôle pour autant cette réforme ne
peut réussir que si elle ne déstabilise
pas les règles de sûreté et de sécurité
la disponibilité des compétences et
Infiné la confiance du public c'est
pourquoi l'examen du projet de loi
soumis au Sénat doit être approfondi et
exigeant en pesant les avantages mais
aussi les inconvénients de la réforme je
rappelle comme l'a fait d'ailleurs le
président longjot que la commission des
affaires économiques que j'ai l'honneur
de présider à la suite de Sophie prima a
expurgé la loi nouveau nucléaire du 22
juin 2023 de toute référence au premier
projet de réforme pour lui préférer une
saisine de l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques lopex en rejetant les
amendements qui avaient été présentés à
la hâte par le gouvernement après le
vote massif du Sénat sur ce texte nous
nous sommes opposés à une réforme mal
anticipée et mal évaluer en saisissant
l'OPEX nous avons remis les
parlementaires au cœur des enjeux je
constate de fait que le nouveau projet
de loi est plus abouti il est le fruit
des travaux préalables de l'OPEX d'une
dizaines de cisines d'organismes
consultatifs et d'un an de concertation
social il arrive donc à un moment
crucial où la France s'apprête à se
fixer de nouveaux objectifs de
construction de réacteur nucléaire dont
le projet de loi relatif à la
souveraineté énergétique dont nous
aurons à débattre prochainement qui
définira notre prochain cap énergétique
également la programmation
pluri-annuelle de l'énergie qui
déclinera ce cap réglementairement aussi
je souhaiterais monsieur le président
vous poser quatre questions en premier
lieu au regard des exemples étrangers
quels sont les bénéfices attendus d'un
modèle de sureté nucléaire et de
radioprotection intégré tel que pratiqué
aujourd'hui aux États-Unis au
Royaume-Uni ou en Espagne ce modèle
a-t-il un impact positif avéré sur la
fluidité des processus sur le partage
des informations et sur l'attractivité
des métiers en second lieu que
pensez-vous du calendrier proposé par le
gouvernement pour réaliser la réforme
cette réforme source inévitable de
désorganisation met-elle en risque la
relance de la filière française du
nucléaire à l'inverse est-elle une
nécessité pour faire face à l'afflux des
dossiers de création de réacteurs
nucléaires ou des dossiers de
prolongation autre point que pensez-vous
des suites données dans le nouveau
projet de loi au rapport de l'OPEX
s'agissant des recommandations sur la
séparation entre l'expertise et la
décision ou sur la publication des
rapports et des avis le renvoi au
règlement intérieur de la future
autorité de sûreté est-il adapté et
certaines recommandations ne sont-elles
pas omises je pense ici à la nécessité
selon l'OPEX du rappel du caractère
indépendant de l'autorité dans son
intitulé du renforcement des groupes
permanents d'experts de la
l'amélioration de la gestion de crise de
l'institution d'un département de
recherche ou encore de la coordination
entre sûreté et sécurité nucléaire enfin
au-delà de cette réforme quelle est
votre vision de la sûreté nucléaire et
de la radioprotection de demain car nous
nous apprêtons je l'ai dit à légiférer
pour les prochaines décennies la mise en
service des premiers réacteurs
nucléaires n'est n'étant pas attendu
avant
2036-237 dans ce contexte ne faut-il pas
mieux intégrer les nouveaux risques tels
que la résilience des réacteurs
nucléaires au changement climatique et
leur
cyberrésilience ne faut-il pas mieux
tenir compte des nouveaux acteurs du
nucléaire dont les opérateurs des petits
réacteurs modulairire c'est un point
d'attention pour notre commission qui a
complété en ce sens notre arsenal
législatif dans la loi nouveau nucléaire
du 22 juin
2023 je vous remercie et et donc à mon
tour je vous laisse la parole avant que
nos deux rapporteurs puissent
effectivement vous poser un certain
nombre de questions merci
beaucoup très bien merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente messieurs les rapporteurs
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
merci de de nous accueillir pour cette
audition consacrée à la réforme du
contrôle de la sûreté nucléaire et de la
radioprotection comme vous l'avez
j'interviendrai de façon liminaire de
manière assez courte et nous répondrons
avec Olivier Gupta directeur général de
de laasn ici présent à vos questions
j'avoue madame la Présidente que je je
ne sais pas si je dois répondre à toutes
vos questions dans les propos liminire
mais ell reviendront si vous en étiez
d'accord je pense que nous pourrions
procéder de cette manière merci beaucoup
alors le le 20 décembre
2023 le Conseil des ministres a validé
un projet de loi visant à créer une
nouvelle autorité
indépendante chargée du contrôle de la
sûreté nucléaire et de la
radioprotection ce projet s'appuie sur
les recommandations de l'opexte vous
l'avez raconté raconté rappelé pardon
dans son rapport de mi juuillet dernier
la création de cette autorité est
motivée selon le gouvernement par les
perspectives de développement du
nucléaire inégalé depuis le plan Mesmer
il y a 50 ans pour faire face aux enjeux
majeurs de souveraineté énergétique et
pour lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique une réflexion sur
l'organisation du système de contrôle
actuel dans un tel contexte n'est pas
illégitime c'est la responsabilité du
gouvernement de le proposer une réforme
s'il l'estime nécessaire et c'est bien
entendu la responsabilité du Parlement
d'en décider le système actuel de
contrôle à 20 ans il est le résultat
d'évolution successive intervenu à à
l'occasion d'étape important en terme de
choix de politique nucléaire et de
retour d'expérience d'événements
marquants concernant la sûreté nucléaire
et la radioprotection tant en France
qu'à l'étranger ce système a fait ses
preuves en temps de paix c'est-à-dire
avec un parc d'installation à contrôler
stable voire en
décroissance cependant si les nouvelles
perspectives de développement du
nucléaire perspective particulièrement
ambitieus dans notre pays sont confirmés
dans les 20 ans qui viennent le système
en place devra affronter un contexte
hors norme sans précédent depuis le
début de l'épopée nucléaire en France
pour lequel il n'a pas été conçu ce sera
un contexte hors norme en terme de
charge de travail et d'autorisation à
délivrer tant sur les installations
existantes que pour le nouveau nucléaire
dans un environnement en en pleine
mutation avec de nouveaux acteurs de
nouvelles technologies vous avez évoqué
les SMR et de nouveaux usages du
nucléire le système de contrôle devra en
outre anticiper les enjeux liés au
dérèglement climatique vous l'avez
souligné mais aussi à l'innovation et au
développement des usages numériques dont
l'intelligence artificielle tant dans
les domaines de la sûreté que de la
radioprotection dans le secteur médical
mais aussi dans le secteur Industri
dans un tel contexte l'organisation
actuelle ne pourra pas assurer ses
missions avec efficacité sans un
renforcement substantiel de ses moyens
et de ses compétences et sans une
évolution de son organisation et de ses
modes de
fonctionnement ce point est central et
se posera quel que soit le système qui
sera
retenu le système de contrôle devra à la
fois changer d'échelle gagner en
efficacité et éviter la dispersion des
compétences techniques et scientifiques
rares dans un contexte de tension sur
les ressources il lui faudra développer
de nouveaux modes de dialogue technique
moins séquencés qu'actuellement et plus
adapté aux phases de maturation et de
mode de gestion des projets qui lui sont
présentés dès lors pour rendre ces
évolutions
réalisables il n'est pas hors de propos
d'envisager un système dans lequel une
seule et même entité maîtrise l'ensemble
des activités nécessairire au contrôle
le choix d'un système intégré est
d'ailleurs celui fait par une grande
majorité des pays occidentaux ayant des
ambitions
nucléaires si cette réforme était
décidée elle devra s'opérer sans
amoindrir le niveau actuel de
transparence ainsi que les compétences
techniques et scientifique de laasn et
de l'IRSN qui sont
indispensables à la confiance du public
dans le
contrôle cela est tout à fait possible
dans une organisation resserrée dont
l'indépendance véritable clé de voûte de
notre système devra être
renforcé ces évolutions et le succès de
leur mise en œuvre supposeront
l'engagement de chacun tant de la S que
de l'IRSN et de leur personnel ainsi
qu'une ambition porteuse de
sens les personnels des deux entités
sont fortement engagés dans leur mission
et je tiens à leur rendre
hommage une bonne partie d'entre eux se
connaissent s'apprécient travaillent
ensemble des parcours croisés existent
entre les deux entités au bénéfice de
tous tous les personnels techniques de
la SN et de l'IRSN dispose d'une
formation de haut niveau et aucun n'est
ignorant de la science la SN et l'IRSN
font beaucoup ensemble et séparément
pour impliquer les parties prenantes
dans les processus d'instruction de
dialogue technique et de concertation et
pour développer une culture de sécurité
et de radioprotection au sein de la
population il est tout à fait possible
de créer un système intégré au moins
aussi sûr et transparent que le système
actuel s'il est créé ce système
bénéficiera comme aujourd'hui de l'appui
de groupes permanents d'experts
pluralistes et externes à l'autorité qui
permettent un débat riche et une prise
de recul par rapport aux conclusions des
expertises et aux arguments des
industriels face à cela il ne me paraît
guerre rationnel de prétendre comme
certains le fond que le système de
contrôle risque de s'effondrer d'ici 10
à 15 ans si la fusion était décidée un
tel système intégré existe depuis
longtemps à l'étranger dans des pays qui
ont un niveau d'expertise scientifique
et d'exigen comparables aux nôtres l'ASN
et l'IRSN sont deux entités dont
l'excellence est reconnu tant en France
qu'à l'étranger et qui partage la même
raison d'être celle de la protection de
la population et de l'environnement il y
a pas de raison objective de penser que
cette excellence et cette raison d'être
commune disparaîtrai au seul motif que
les deux entités seraient fusionné au
sein d'une nouvelle autorité
indépendante c'est au contraire cette
excellence dans tous les domaines de la
recherche à l'inspection en passant par
l'expertise et la décision et c'est la
reconnaissance comme référence
internationale dans tous ces domaines
d'activité qui doivent être au cœur des
ambitions de la nouvelle autorité si sa
création était décidée voilà monsieur le
Président Madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs ce que je
souhaitais dire en introduction et bien
évidemment je reviendrai sur toutes les
questions que vous avez soulevé madame
la Présidente au cours du débat
merci merci Monsieur le le Président je
je vais donner la parole à notre
rapporteur Pascal
[Musique]
Martin merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de
laasn le président longjot a rappelé il
y a quelques minutes la priorité qui a
guidé mon travail en tant que rapporteur
pour la Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
sur ce projet de loi relatif à la sûreté
nucléaire et plus particulièrement à sa
gouvernance il convient d'évoquer est le
maintien de notre sûreté nucléaire à un
niveau d'exigence le plus élevé possible
en l'adaptant aux enjeux de notre décenn
et de celles à venir j'ai organisé
durant les premières semaines de janvier
une vingtaine d'auditions afin
d'entendre l'ensemble des parties
prenantes sur ce texte j'ai également
souhaité travailler pense en très bonne
intelligence avec la commission des
affaires économiques saisie pour avis
sur le fond sur quatre articles du
projet de loi de finance du projet de
loi de sur sur la sûreté nucléaire
pardon certaines de ces auditions ont
ainsi été organisées conjointement avec
Patrick chaise dans un excellent climat
et je m'en
faélicite monsieur le Président nous
vous avons déjà entendu au tout début du
cycle d'audition c'était d'ailleurs la
première audition au terme de ces
différentes auditions j'ai identifié
cinq enjeux centraux sur lequels je
souhaiterais vous entendre premier enjeu
l'humain la sûreté nucléaire repose
d'abord sur des
compétences sur des experts et des
chercheurs qui doivent être au cœur de
notre réflexion je l'avais déjà rappelé
en tant que rapporteur budgétaire sur
les crédits relatifs à la prévention des
risques la relance du nucléaire
nécessitera la création de 100000 postes
durant les 10 prochaines années dans ce
contexte fortement concurrentiel nous
devons être particulièrement attentif à
assurer l'attractivité de la sûreté
nucléaire dans l'hypothèse de la
création d'une nouvelle autorité de
sûreté nucléaire comment la nouvelle
autorité de sûrté nucléaire et de
radioprotection pourrait-elle être
suffisamment
attractive notamment pour les jeunes
chercheurs et experts comment éviter que
la période de transition
indispensable entre l'ancienne et la
nouvelle organisation ne se traduisent
pas par une fuite de compétences deuxème
enjeu non moins important la
transparence les Français ont
aujourd'hui très largement confiance en
la robustesse de notre système de sûreté
nucléaire cette confiance elle est le
fruit vous l'avez rappelé d'un travail
de plusieurs décennies de tous les
acteur qui s'est notamment traduit par
un effort accru d'information légitime
du public pour assurer l'acceptabilité
de la relance du nucléaire il est à mon
sens souhaitable de continuer à
renforcer cette
transparence l'exposé des motifs du
projet de loi évoque je cite une
transparence renforcée vis-à-vis du
public comment l'ASN
renforcerait-elle selon vous la
transparence de la sûreté nucléaire
alors que l'IRSN publie aujourd'hui
l'ensemble de ces avis
d'expertise comment la future autorité
pourrait-elle assurer un niveau au moins
équivalent de publication trè enjeu la
distinction entre expertise et
décision c'est un principe fondamental
de notre système de sûreté nucléaire qui
a été évoqué tout au long de nos
auditions dans l'organisation actuelle
les décisions en matière de sûreté
nucléaire sont prises par l'ASN tandis
que l'expertise est généralement délégué
à l'IRSN pour les décisions les plus
importantes la réforme propose
d'intégrer expertise et décision au sein
d'une même autorité dans un souci de
simplification administrative renforçant
la lisibilité et l'opérationalité des
services quelle forme monsieur le
Président pourrait prendre la
distinction entre expertise et décision
au sein de l'organisation unique
proposée par le gouvernement 4è et
avant-dernière enjeu la recherche l'IRSN
exerce aujourd'hui une activité de
recherche en matière de sûreté nucléaire
qui nourrit son activité d'expertise
cette recherche appliquée dont
l'excellence est reconnue
internationalement serait conservée dans
le cadre de la future
asnr le transfert à une autorité
administrative indépendante d'activité
de recherche peut
susciter quelques interrogation la
recherche nécessite de nombreux
partenariats avec d'autres
établissements de recherche mais aussi
avec les principaux industriels du
nucléaire qui seront également contrôlés
par la future autorité
l'asnr pourrait-elle poursuivre les
partenariats engagés entre l'IRSN et les
principaux industriel du nucléaire sans
risque déontologique de conflit
d'intérêt enfin
le dernier enjeu que j'identifie est
plus juridique madame la Présidente
estros Sasson l'a évoqué il s'agit des
conditions d'élaboration du règlement
intérieur de la future autorité j'ai pu
constater au cours de mes auditions que
la plupart des sujets les plus sensibles
relatifs notamment à la déontologie à la
publication des travaux d'expertise et à
la distinction entre expertise et
décision sont renvoyés légitimement là
encore on peut le comprendre au
règlement tri de la future autorité
cette option a l'avantage de la
souplesse il ne faut pas tout figer dans
la loi si le législateur fait le choix
de la
fusion les grandes orientations devront
être décidé par le législateur puis la
SNR devra les appliquer dans son
règlement intérieur c'est le principe
même d'une autorité administrative
indépendante cette solution plus souple
peut présenter cependant un inconvénient
il n'est pas garanti que les solutions
adoptées par
laasnr pardon soi totalement conforme à
l'esprit du législateur comment et c'est
ma dernière question monsieur le
Président garantir que sur des enjeux
aussi cruciaux que la déontologie la
transparence et la distinction entre
expertise et décision la volonté du
Parlement soit respectée vous
semble-t-il
envisageable de prévoir par exemple la
sisine pour avis de l'opexte
sur le projet de règlement intérieur de
la future asnr je vous remercie de votre
attention merci monsieur le rapporteur
donc nous allons maintenant donner la
parole au rapporteur de la commission
des affaires économiques Patrick
chez monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues comme vous le savez la
commission des affaires économiques dont
je suis le rapporteur sur ce projet de
loi est saisie de l'examen au fond de
quatre articles sur les réformes du Haut
Commissaire à l'énergie atomique et les
règles de la commande publique applica
au projet de réacteur nucléaire elle est
saisie de l'examen pour avis des autres
articles du texte ayant trait à la
réforme de la gouvernance de la sûreté
nucléaire et de la
radioprotection dans le cadre de mes
travaux préalables toujours en cours
j'ai entendu une quarantaine de
personnalités à l'occasion d'une
vingtaine d'auditions je remercie le
rapporteur Pascal Martin de la qualité
de nos échanges pour les auditions que
nous avons pu mener en
commun à mon tour je souhaiterais
monsieur le Président vous poser
plusieurs questions sur la réforme
proposée par le
gouvernement ma première question
concerne l'application de cette réforme
d'une part contenu de la nécessité pour
la nouvelle autorité d'élaborer un
règlement intérieur voyez j'y viens
aussi éte faer et de négocier des
conventions collectives l'échéance du
1er janvier 2025 est-elle
tenable d'autre part votre mandat devra
prendre fin en
2024 sans possibilité de renouvellement
ne faudrait-il pas prévoir dès
aujourd'hui la désignation d'un
préfigurateur ma deuxième question porte
sur le statut de la future autorité si
le statut d'autorité administrative
indépendante est de nature à garantir
l'indépendance de cette nouvelle
instance celui d'autorité publique
indépendante lui aurait conféré une
autonomie budgétaire et une souplesse de
gestion regrettez-vous le choix opéré
par le
gouvernement ma troisème question
concerne les missions de la future
autorité lors de votre audition par
notre commission le 8 mars 2023 sur le
premier projet de réforme proposé par le
gouvernement dans le cadre de la loi
nouveau nucléaire du 22 juin 2023 vous
aviez regretté que la sécurité des
installations nucléaires civiles
ne figure pas parmi les missions de la
nouvelle autorité est-ce toujours votre
opposition ma 4è question porte sur
l'organisation de la future autorité le
projet de texte renvoie à son règlement
intérieur la séparation entre les
processus d'expertise et d'instruction
conduit par les services d'une part et
les processus d'élaboration des avis et
des décisions pris par le collège
d'autre part ne faut-il pas viser
d'autres
actes les cas où les décisions sont
prises par le collège sont peu nombreux
lors de 40 je crois ne faudrait-il pas
étendre ce champ de
compétence le projet de texte renvoie
également au règlement intérieur le soin
de définir les activités d'expertise et
d'instruction qui devont faire l'objet
de publication est-ce que cela offre des
garanties
suffisantes certains rapports avis ou
décision ne devrait-il pas être d'emblé
rendu public sous réserve des secret
protégés par la
loi ma 5e série de question porte sur le
personnel de la future
autorité tout d'abord la réforme
garantira-t-elle l'accueil des salariés
de l'IRSN dans des conditions
équivalentes à leur situation
actuelle plus encore la complexité des
instances de représentation des
personnels et des modalités de
négociation des convention collective ne
fait-elle pas peser le risque d'une
autorité déséquilibrée à de vitesse
entre les agents publics et les agents
privés enfin la jurisprudence
constitutionnelle prohibbe la délégation
de fonction inséparabl de la
souveraineté nationale à des agents
étrangers de même que la recherche
d'infraction pénal par des agents privés
ne faudrait-il pas inscrire ces
gardes-fous s'agissant des personnels
habilités je vous remercie d'avance pour
vos
réponses
bien merci messieurs les rapporteurs
donc Monsieur D vous allez répondre à
nos
rapporteurs bien écoutez merci monsieur
le Président merci madame la Présidente
et et Messieurs les les rapporteurs vous
avez posé de de très nombreuses
questions mais heureusement certaines de
ces questions se recoupent et je me
permettrai de de de les
rassembler tout d'abord je voudrais
revenir sur le la question que vous
posiez madame la Présidente en ce qui
concerne finalement
l'enjeuin et ce que l'on peut attendre
d'une telle réforme je je pense comme je
je l'ai indiqué dans mon propos
liminaire que la situation face à
laquelle nous allons nous trouver dans
les 20 ans qui viennent si bien
évidemment les les projets
gouvernementaux qui viendront dans le
cadre d'une loi différente vous l'avez
souligné en terme d'ambition nucléaire
pour le pays était adopté nous aurons à
faire face à des à un volume de travail
que nous n'avons jamais rencontré y
compris lors de la l'épopée nucléaire
des années 80- 90 à l'époque il
s'agissait de construire un parc certes
puissant mais de réacteur alors qu'il
n'y avait pas encore en charge à gérer
le passé aujourd'hui nous avons à la
fois à nous interroger sur la poursuite
de fonctionnement de ce parc de 56
réacteurs nous avons à travailler sur le
démantellement des installations
anciennes qui ont été mises à l'arrêt et
en parallèle nous avons à nous mobiliser
sur les nouveaux projets qu'il s'agisse
des gros réacteurs comme le PR2 ou qu'il
s'agisse des petits réacteurs qui sont
très innovants comme les
SMR tout cela représente une charge de
travail que nous n'avons jamais connu et
donc il faut vous l'avez souligné vous
avez cité le mot rechercher une
organisation qui soit efficace mais qui
préserve bien évidemment les acquis du
dispositif tel que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui en terme de transparence et
en terme de de culture de de de sûreté
et d'exigence de sûreté c'est possible
je l'ai dit dans mon introduction mais
lorsque l'on se compare à à nos
homologues étrangers il y a de très
nombreux pays dans le monde qui ont une
organisation resserré c'est le cas aux
États-Unis au Canada en Grande-Bretagne
au Japon en Finlande des pays qui ont
qui ont des des projets de développement
nucléaire et il y a une intégration à la
fois des phases d'expertise et des
phases de décision et certaines de ces
autorité dispose également de capacités
de recherche donc un tel système vers
lequel il est proposé d'évoluer existe à
l'étranger et il a me semble-t-il montré
sa sa robustesse il n'y a d'ailleurs pas
de débat au niveau international sur le
niveau d'exigence et le niveau de
d'expertise scientifique de ces
autorités qui est un très haut niveau
également donc on peut tout à fait
imaginer je pense que la souci
d'efficacité la réduction des délais
d'instruction qui aujourd'hui se sont
des délis qui tiennent compte du fait
qu'il y a deux autorités sous des
gouvernances
différentes peut-être un objectif pour
la mise en place de la nouvelle autorité
il y a nécessairement quand il y a deux
autorités deux entités infictionnel
d'une certaine manière une organisation
d'interface à gérer une seule autorité
et de ce point de vue un moyen plus aisé
de mettre en place des procédures qui
sont plus adaptées au à la gestion des
des demandes qui nous sont formulées il
y a un certain nombre de doublons de
redondan qui existe aujourd'hui entre
l'ASN et l'IRSN je vais citer quelques
exemples nous avons deux organisations
de
crise il y a lorsqu'un événement se
produit il y a d'abord une sollicitation
de l'IRSN en tant qu'expert qui imagine
au vu du des informations dont il
dispose les possibilités de
développement de ces situations
accidentelles et propose à l'ASN c'est
la loi qui le prévoit propose à la des
mesures qui sont à mettre en œuvre en
terme de protection des population qui
s'agisse d'évacuation qui s'agisse de
confinement qui s'agisse de prise de
comprimé d'Ode ces mesures sont
analysées bien évidemment par laasn et
c'est l'ASN qui au vu de son analyse
porte ses recommandations auprès du
gouvernement qui est le décideur ceci
introduit un chaînage qui est d'une
certaine manière frictionnel également
et et il conviendrait dans une
organisation unique d'avoir un une
gestion de crise unique et un centre de
crise unique nous avons le part et
d'autre des relations internationales
nous sommes comme l'un et l'autre
reconnu à très comme procédant à très
haut niveau d'expertise et d'exigence au
niveau international il m'arrive parfois
de me déplacer enfin souvent d'ailleurs
de me déplacer mais parfois il m'arrive
d'avoir mes homologues qui ont les
capacités de décision et d'expertis au
sein de leurs mêmes autorités qui me dit
bah tiens le mois dernier j'ai vu l'IRSN
ou le mois prochain je verrai l'IRSN et
nous parlons des mêmes sujets qui sont
nos sujets communs hein ce n'est pas
efficace lorsque nous sommes dans des
discussions internationales à laors
qu'il y a des décisions à prendre sur
l'évolution des règles de sûreté ou des
problématiques nouvelles par exemple
quels sont les niveaux d'exigence de
sûreté sur les nouveaux réacteurs les
SMR où là on est tous d'une certaine
manière de confrontés au au même
démarrage dans le monde entier porter
une voix unique de la France en terme
d'expertise et de décision sera beaucoup
plus robuste et puis il y a bien sûr la
totalité du processus du processus
d'instruction avec la phase d'expertise
la phase d'analyse avant proposition de
décision auprès du collège lorsque pour
les décisions les plus importantes qui
aujourd'hui est un un un processus qui
comporte des interfaces puisque ce sont
deux entités différentes qui ont des
priorités qui peuvent être différentes
la priorité d'instruction en fonction
des enjeux il faut qu'il une seule
autorité qui le dessine au c'est
décideur qui décide donc voyez-vous
voilà toute une série d'avantages qui me
semble extrêmement important de de
souligner euh dans la mise en place du
du nouveau dispositif alors quels sont à
la limite les risques les risques c'est
ont été évoqué à plusieurs reprises par
vous-même par par les rapporteurs
d'abord il y a d'abord un sujet qui est
j'aime bien cette expression du du du
rapporteur Martin l'humain je pense que
nos missions sont reposes
essentiellement sur une expertise sur
une compétence qui repose sur les hommes
et les femmes qui constituent les deux
entités et face au au aux enjeux et au
volume de travail que j'ai j'évoqué
cette ces ressources humaines vont être
extrêmement sollicité d'ailleurs il
faudra les renforcer quelle que soit la
décision qui sera prise et
substantiellement si nous'avons pas des
renforts de manière substantielle nous
ne tiendrons pas la route C n'est pas
possible de l'imaginer et ces hommes et
ces femmes je l'ai souligné travaillent
déjà aujourd'hui ensemble ils ont la
même raison d'être il n'y a pas nous
sommes pas en concurrence d'une certain
manière on n'est pas avec deux visions
différentes nous n'avons l'un et l'autre
qu'une seule mission c'est la protection
des personnes et de l'environnement il
n'y a pas une entité qui serait avec une
capacité scientifique d'analyse et une
autre qui prendrait des enjeux r compte
des enjeux autres que Cell de la sûreté
nucléaire et de la radioprotection ce
n'est pas vrai parfois j'entends cela en
disant oui mais la SN tient compte de
d'autres circonstances ou d'autres
éléments qui viendrai ici ou là
perturber la la l'analyse
scientifique du sujet non c'est pas vrai
nous avons exactement la même raison
d'être et nous sommes nous appuyons sur
les mêmes éléments laasn est composée à
70 % d'ingénieurs d'experts de de
d'univers itire de médecins de de
pharmaciens nous ne sommes pas ignorant
de la science il y a pas d'un côté une
expertise scientifique éclairée par la
science et de l'autre côté une expertise
réglementaire qui qui ne connaîtrait pas
les bases scientifiques donc voyez-vous
je je pense que c'est ces sujets lié à
l'humain à la manière de travailler
ensemble qui existe déjà sont les sujets
qu'il faut absolument prendre en compte
pour que cette cette décision si elle
est confirmée de fusion soit un succès
et tout ça dans un contexte a été
rappelé il y a un chiffre a été cité un
contexte de forte tension sur les
ressources il a été dit que dans les 10
années qui viennent il y a 100000
collaborateurs qui devront être recrutés
par la filière nucléaire c'est vrai
10000 par an ça met une tension sur les
ressources qui est considérable et dès à
présent un certain nombre de personnes
qui sont notamment des experts ou des
chercheurs de l'IRSN sont sont
sollicités par soit des exploitants
actuels soit des futurs exploitants dans
le casadre des SMR et qu' offre le offre
des des des déroulements de carrière
avec des des des conditions financières
qui sont assez avantageuses donc il y a
il y a un risque si nous n'avons pas une
politique ambitieuse en matière de
d'attractivité de la future autorité il
y a un risque qu'il estit de perte de
compétenence et il faut s'en occuper
immédiatement et quelle que soit
d'ailleurs la décision qui qui sera
prise donc je je je milite pour que il y
ait effectivement des décisions fortes
en terme d'attractivité et je pense pour
revenir à à la question de des avantages
qu'avoir une une entité unique
comportant de multiples métiers et
activités composé de de plus de 2200 ou
2300 personnes c'est aussi un moyen
d'offrir des parcours de carrière à
l'intérieur de l'autorité avec
différentes missions tout au long de la
carrière c'est aussi un argument
d'attractivité qu'il faut intégrer et il
me semble que c'est positif
ensuite par rapport aux questions que
que vous vous posiez il y a il y a la
question bien évidemment du calendrier
de la réforme ça a été posé à plusieurs
reprises si la réforme est décidée et je
le lis au sujet de de de ressources
humaines qu'on vient d'évoquer et face à
la charge de travail que que j'ai cité
nous sommes dans une phase de de montter
en charge qui est importante elle est
importante dès dès à présent elle le
sera encore plus dans les 3o 4 ans qui
viennent j'estime que le pic d'activité
cont tenu de l'ensemble des projets et
et des des des intentions qui ont été
affichées par le gouvernement ou les
exploitants devrai se produire plutôt
vers 2027 ou 2028 en terme de charge de
travail mais ça monte déjà et donc si on
veut tirer bénéfice d'une réforme du
système de contrôle il faut le faire
maintenant si on attendait ce serait
plus possible de le faire avec une
charge de travail qui va encore monter
dans d'ici 2027 et 2028 et si cette
réforme est décidée il ne faut pas qu'il
y ait d'incertitude entretenue vis-à-vis
des personnels il faut que les
personnels des deux entités sachent le
plus tôt possible si la réforme est
décidée et les conditions dans
lesquelles elle sera mise en place et la
date du 1er janvier 2025 est ambitieuse
mais elle est nécessaire si il y a trop
de période d'incertitude cela risque
d'augmenter ce que vous signaliez en
terme de de départ hein de de de de
départ de personnel ne voyons pas
clairement quels sont les les les les
rôles qu'ils auront à jouer les les les
poste qu'ils auront à à à à tenir dans
la future
autorité vous avez posé à plusieurs
reprises la question de la la
distinction entre expertise et décision
comme étant un sujet qui préoccupe bien
évidemment et c'est tout à fait légitime
lorsque l'on est en en face à une telle
évolution
d'organisation je pense qu'il y a
d'abord deux questions à se poser à
poser la première question c'est celle
mais finalement une autorité de décision
comme l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
peut-elle disposer en son sein d'une
capacité d'expertise interne la réponse
est clairement oui il n'y a aucune
règles et notamment dans le domaine
nucléaire qui interdisent à une autorité
de sûreté nucléaire et de
radioprotection de disposer en interne
d'une capacité d'expertise d'avoir une
expertise intégrée et donc de ne pas
faire appel sauf cas particulier à une
expertise externe d'ailleurs les
nombreux cas que je cité exemple à
l'étranger existent et nos homologues à
l'étranger sont comme nous euh obligé de
respecter les règles internationales et
sont évalués sur le respect de ces
règles internationales qui sont fixées
par laiaa donc c'est c'est oui
clairement oui on peut avoir une fusion
c'est ceux qui disent non non c'est pas
c'est c'est pas normal c'est pas dans
les règles ce n'est pas vrai et
d'ailleurs pour contrôler et et pour
pouvoir décider de manière responsable
une autorité indépendante doit
nécessairement disposer des compétences
internes et et de de haut niveau hein je
dirais que cela cela serait est une
condition nécessaire à l'exercice d'un
contrôle indépendant il s'agit pas de
faire de recopier des avis qui sont émis
par l'extérieur il s'agit de d'avoir une
véritable analyse une capacité de
challenge de ce qui est proposé par les
industriels mais aussi éventuellement
par les experts que nous sollicitons
lorsque nous en avons besoin donc la la
la nécessité d'une capacité d'expertise
interne est absolument euh nécessaire et
quand on regarde les les autorités
indépendantes en France les autres dans
les autres domaines et ben elles ont
certaines d'entre elles en tout cas
elles ont une capacité interne
d'expertise et donc c'est la réponse est
clairement oui on peut tout à fait
rassembler fusionner dans une salle et
même entité une expertise et la seconde
question c'est celle finalement de quand
on est dans une telle configuration
comment distinguons-nous comment
devons-nous distinguer la phase
d'expertise interne et la phase de
décision interne et ça c'est tout à fait
tout à fait important alors quand on
regarde la situation actuelle la manière
dont nous fonctionnons avec l'IRSN alors
face à une demande ben contrairement à
ce que certains prétendent il y a pas de
barrière étanche entre les équipes de la
SN et des équipes de l'IRSN pendant la
totalité du processus d'expertise les
les équipes de l'ASN sont associées aux
équipes de l'IRSN il y a des échanges il
y a des échanges avec les exploitants le
dialogue technique est continu pendant
la phase d'expertise comme il est est
d'ailleurs une fois l'expertise rendue
continue dans la phase de préparation de
la décision donc il n'y a pas de
séparation étanche entre les les deux
entités pour autant il faut des règles
pour autant il faut des des des mesures
qui qui permettent effectivement de
distinguer la responsabilité de l'expert
de la responsabilité du décideur donc ça
je pense que c'est un principe qui
devrait clairement figurer dans la loi
pour qu'il y ait une séparation une
distinction pardon entre la la
responsabilité de l'expert et la
responsabilité du décideur et ceci quel
que soit et je reviendrai sur une
question que vous avez posé quelle que
soit la situation de recours ou non à
une expertise parce qu'il y a des cas où
nous n'avons pas besoin de faire appel à
une expertise parce que les les
personnes qui décident disposent
eux-même de la compétence pour décider
mais ce principe de séparation me semble
important il faut l'inscrire dans la loi
et par rapport à la question que vous
posez les modalités vous avez posé
finalement à plusieurs reprises la
question du règlement intérieur bah les
modalités d'application de ce principe
doivent être définies dans le règlement
intérieur d'abord pourquoi d'abord c'est
le principe même c'est la loi loi
organique de de 2017 concernant la
totalité des autorités administratives
ou euh publi indépendant qui définissent
ce principe en disant c'est la loi qui
définit les les grands principes de
fonctionnement de ces autorités et c'est
le règlement intérieur c'est dans la loi
de 2017 qui définit les modalités
d'application est-ce que ce règlement
intérieur qui en tant qu'autorité
indépendante bien évidemment il doit
être préparé et et validé ininé par le
par l'autorité indépendante est-ce que
ce au cours du processus d'élaboration
de ce règlement intérieur est-ce qu'il y
a des consultations est-ce qu'il y a des
des avis des présentation des projets
qui peuvent être organisés ben bien sûr
il me semble tout à fait légitime que le
Parlement souhaite dans le processus de
d'élaboration du règlement intérieur qui
sera validé par l'autorité par le
collège de l'autorité c'est d'ailleurs
dans la loi de 2017 qu'il y ait des
phases d'échange et des phases de
concertation et je pense de ce point de
vue-là que c'est au Parlement de décider
quels seraient les interlocuteurs de
l'autorité pour pouvoir avoir cet
échange sur le projet de règlement
intérieur ça peut être l'OPEX ça peut
être les comm mission c'est à vous à le
décider mais je pense que cette phase de
consultation elle peut tout à fait être
retenue comme étant un
principe donc voilà en ce qui concerne
la séparation expertise décision il me
semble que le point focal c'est
véritablement la distinction entre la
responsabilité d'expertise et la
responsabilité ce ne sont pas les mêmes
personnes ce sont des personnes
différentes qui de qui doivent pouvoir
être mobilisés sur ces deux sujets vous
avez évoqué les question de transparence
à plusieurs reprises alors la question
de la transparence tout d'Ur je dois je
le dis et je l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises nous disposons aujourd'hui en
France dans le domaine nucléire d'une
transparence qui
est extrêmement développée
comparativement à à ce qui existe dans
le monde nous nous avons de nombreuses
actions en matière d'information
d'association de transparence de
dialogue technique d'association de la
société civile au processus que nous
déroulons et aux décisions que que nous
prenons c'est un modèle qui est pas
unique mais enfin qui est très
développé que je suis amené d'ailleurs
régulièrement à présenter à mes
homologues qui qui essaent de s'en
inspirer donc il faut le préserver et je
ne vois pas en quoi la mise en place du
nouveau d'une nouvelle autorité
rassemblant deux entités qui l'une et
l'autre ou en même temps ensemble pardon
réalisent des des actions de
d'information de transparence ou de
concertation pourrait conduire à à à
menuiser ce ce niveau ce ha niveau de
transparence et et d'information donc
franchement je je je pense que c'est un
un sujet qui qui qui ne doit pas être un
sujet d'inquiétude je pense que le
projet de loi va même plus loin que ce
qui existe actuellement notamment il
prévoit et c'est tout à fait logique et
et c'est légitime par rapport au aux
demandes que auquelles nous trouvons
c'est de dire ben pour certains sujets
bien sûr pas pour tout mais pour
certains sujets qui sont des sujets en
général à fort enjeu pour lequel il y a
il y a un souhait de l'ensemble des des
parties prenantes d'être parties prenant
justement en processus et ben il faut
afficher d'entrée de jeu lorsque l'on
démarre une instruction que sur ces
sujets il y aura une association
particulière des publics à différentes
étapes de l'expertise et de
l'instruction ce qui supposera bien
évidemment que les résultats
intermédiaires des expertises et des
instructions soi rendu public sinon on
peut pas associer les personnes mais il
faut le cibler sur les mission les
sujets qui sont à Fort en jeu bien
évidemment je peux en citer quelques-uns
pour donner quelques exemples par
exemple la poursuite d'exploitation des
réacteur du parc de DF au-delà de 50 ans
ou de 60 ans c'est un véritable sujet
bon bah sur un sujet comme celui-là nous
avons déjà organisé des des des avec
d'ailleurs le Haut Comité pour la
transparence et sur la sûreté
l'information et la sûreté sur la sûreté
nucléaire nous avons organisé tout au
long du processus d'instruction des
phases de rendez-vous vous avec les CLIS
avec les les avec la population avec les
parties prenantes pour pouvoir exposer
où nous en étions pour pouvoir tenir
compte de leur avis dans le processus de
décision il y a un autre exemple sur
lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
configuration homologue c'est la
décision que nous allons serener
apprendre pour la mise en service de 6Go
c'est un un processus d'instruction qui
est relativement long nous avons la
demande d'autorisation de création en
cours d'instruction de de la part de de
landra et la décision que nous prendrons
sera à l'horizon 2027 20 28 qui fait
d'ailleurs référence à ce que je disais
en terme de charge de travail bon ben
nous avons décidé d'avoir un processus
étager par étape qui conduira à des
échanges avec la population donc ce que
ce qui figure pardon dans le projet de
loi qui paraît une nouveauté quelque
chose de supplémentaire en terme de de
transparence c'est de dire ben
finalement chaque année la future
autorité présentera à l'opexte
présentera au Haut Comité pour la
transparence les sujets sur lesqueles
elle propose qu'il y ait tout au long du
processus d'instruction ce dialogue
technique avec bien évidment publication
des résultats ça c'est une
avancée pour ce qui concerne le reste de
la transparence je veux dire il faut
faire attention à ne pas restreindre la
problématique de la transparence à la
seule publication des avis d'expertise
de
l'IRSN certes c'est un sujet qui est en
débat qu'on met sur la table c'est clair
c'est important mais il y a beaucoup
d'autres publications qui sont
aujourd'hui réalisées et qui ne sont pas
en débat nous réalisons chaque année
1800 inspections les les les conclusions
les rapports de ces inspections sont
tous publiés à l'issue de l'inspection
au fil de l'eau ces rapports
d'inspection je peux vous le dire sont
très largement exploités par les membres
des CLIS par les associations pour
pouvoir interpeller les exploitants
lorsque nous relevons un écart ou
lorsque nous nous nous émettons une
demande forte au motif que l'exploitant
n'est selon nous pas tout à fait en
ligne avec ce que nous attendons bien
évidemment ce même exploitant est
interpellé quasiment immédiatement à la
clique qui suit à la réunion de la C
suit sur la base du rapport d'inspection
1800 rapports il y a 350 avisassen il y
a 1800 rapports par an de l'ASN nous
avons des rapports d'expertise qui sont
réalisés par des groupes permanents
d'experts ce n'est pas l'IRSN c'est un
autre groupe qui va subsister d'ailleurs
qui sont des groupes permanents qui
réunissent des experts scientifiques
universitaire des des représentants
d'autorités
étrangères voilà il y a c'est un groupe
très large des experts non
institutionnel ces groupes permanents
d'experts sur les gros sujets émettent
des avis et ces avis sont publiés nous
avons tout un un travail qui est réalisé
dans le cadre de comité de gestion des
directeur pardon sur les les les
situations postaccidentelles où nous
travaillons sur la culture la sécurité
avec des ateliers qui associent les
riverins
des riverins des installations
nucléaires avec l'aide DESC et tout ça
est public tout ça une forme
d'association pour pouvoir renforcer la
culture de la sécurité de la
radioprotection donc ce que je dis c'est
nous avons un système qui est
extrêmement développé qui est reconnu
qui est en avance par rapport à nos
homologues je ne vois pas de raison
fondamentale à ce que ce système soit
réduit il ne comporte pas il ne s'appuie
pas que sur les expertises de l'IRSN il
est beaucoup plus large que ça et le
projet de loi prévoit une avancée
supplémentaire en terme de de
transparence et qui me paraît tout à
fait tout à fait
bénéfique alors il y a la question de
la la séparation j'ai évoqué la
séparation entre le le l'expertise et la
décision il y a le le travail sur lequel
nous nous nous sommes engagés avec
l'IRSN pour préparer la fusion je
reviens sur la la question du du
calendrier je disais tout à l'heure que
le 1er janvier 2025 et et de mon point
de vue nécessaire cont tenu des des
enjeux d'une part et cont tenu du fait
qu'il ne faut pas prolonger la période
d'incertitude dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons ça ne résulte l'anticipation de
cette échéance n'est pas uniquement une
question liée à la discussion sur le
projet de loi il faut bien évidemment
travailler également c'est ce que nous
avons fait nous avons lancé en accord
avec l'IRSN avec les personnels sur une
réflexion en matière de de préfiguration
de la future autorité donc en terme
d'organisation en terme de de de mise à
plat de certains processus et si vous le
souhaitez on pourra y revenir je donai
la parole à à Olivier guiplat pour qu'il
précise la manière dont le processus
d'instruction et et d'expertise est
aujourd'hui en cours de de je veux
dirais de de finalisation avec avec
l'IRSN donc nous avons nous avons engagé
un travail avec l'ensemble des des des
représentants de de de l'IRSN à travers
des groupes il y a 12 groupes de travail
à travers un comité de de concertation
avec les représentants du personnel pour
pouvoir se préparer au cas où à
l'hypothèse ou finalement la loi serait
votée et donc on fait on met tout on
essaie de mettre de notre côté tout ce
qui est nécessaire pour pouvoir démarrer
manière opérationnelle au premier j
pardon oui je je suis désolé mais
il y a a il y a aussi beaucoup de
questions euh bien donc je je je je je
reviens sur la question que posait
monsieur le rapporteur chaise hein sur
effectivement mon mandat se termine au
mois de novembre c'est lié à ce que je
viens de dire hein donc quel que soit la
décision qui sera prise je je ne serai
pas présent si la la s'il était décidé
de mettre en place la la nouvelle
organisation au 1er janvier vous dites
faut-il désigner un préfigurateur je
pense que ça c'est une question qu'il
faut voir avec les les personnalités qui
sont en charge de la nomination du du
futur président et ça c'est une c'est
une responsabilité qui incombe au
président de de la République mais mais
je suis assez d'accord avec vous sur le
fait que il faudrait démarrer ce
processus
d'identification du du du futur
président de de de l'autorité peut-être
un peu plus tôt que que ce qui était
réalisé précédemment pour que si la loi
était voté par exemple à l'été cette
personne puisse être impliquée un peu
plus tôt non pas le 12 novembre c'est la
date de la fin de mon mandat mais
peut-être dès le début de l'automne sur
la la fin de la mise des discussions qui
ont été engagées avec une véritable
casquette de préfigurateur de la future
autorité puisqu'il aura été identifié
avec bien évidemment l'étape essentielle
que qui devra être celle de la de de de
l'audition par les les les chambres he
des par les commission pardon des des
deux chambres avant de d'être certain
que c'est lui qui qui prendra la
suite alors je je reviens sur deux
sujets et je nauraai pas le temps je
suis désolé je suis trop bavard
d'évoquer tout les questions mais je
reviens sur deux de deux question que
vous avez évoqué qui me semble
importante c'est la question de la
sécurité la séparation entre la sûreté
des installations nucléaires et la
sécurité donc vous m'avez posé la
question qu'est-ce que j'en pense est-ce
que la la position que j'avais exprimée
par le passé est toujours la même alors
je vous confirme que oui que que
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire estime
que la sécurité des installations
nucléaires civiles est un sujet qui
devrait être intimement lié à la sûreté
des installations nucléaires civiles
pourquoi ben parce que les deux sujets
sécurité et sûreté sont intimement liés
les les actes de malveillance qui sont
du ressort de la sécurité ont
nécessairement un impact en terme de
sûreté et donc il faut avoir de notre
point de vue une approche globale des
questions de sécurité et de sûreté
j'avais proposé et mes prédécesseurs
également que la la responsabilité en
tant qu'autorité de la sécurité des
installations civiles soit confondu
rapproché fusionné avec les missions de
l'ASN en matière de sûreté c'est ce qui
se passe à l'étranger la quasi-ttalité
des autorités étrangères ont la double
compéten sécurité et sûreté sur les
installations nucléaires civiles je ne
parle pas des installations nucléaires
de défense il est tout à fait logique
que ça soit traité de manière séparée et
donc Dee certaine manière je regrette le
choix fait par le gouvernement dans le
texte de prévoir que l'expertise en
matière de sécurité des installation
nucléaire civile soit retiré du
portefeuille de la future autorité et
confié à à l'autorité nucléire de
défense qui n n'a pas de compétenence
aujourd'hui particulière sur les
installations nucléaires civiles
donc c'est un voilà c'est un sujet qui
me semble être un sujet sur lequel le le
le Parlement doit se
positionner et je pense que c'est un
sujet qui prend d'autant plus
d'importance dans le futur qui prendra
d'autant plus d'importance dans le futur
notamment avec le développement des SMR
aujourd'hui la sécurité est
assurée avec toute une série de de de de
barrières physiquesin et de moyens de
force de l'ordre pour intervenir en cas
d'intrusion sur un site nucléaire à
partir du moment où on est dans une
perspective d'avoir des installations
des petites installations des micro
installations nucléaires qui soient
diffuses notamment dans le tissu
industriel pour assurer la décarbonation
on ne pourra pas avoir les mêmes
barrières il va falloir avoir une
sécurité comme d'ailleurs une sûreté
intrinsèque qui sera assuré par la
conception même et donc avoir une seule
autorité qui est capable de de
d'englober à travers son expertise et sa
décision les sujets de sécurité de sûté
intrinsèque me semble être la voie qu'il
faudrait privilégier ce n'est pas le
choix fait par le gouvernement je
maintiens la position que nous avions
exprimé bien évidemment nous nous ferons
comme il sera
décidé bien écoutez je je je on va
peut-être ouvrir les
questions et vous aurez certainement
l'opportunité de répondre de N voilà si
je n'ai pas répondu à certaines
questions mais que vous estimez
importante n'hésitez pas
souligner et j'y reviendrai merci bien
merci merci vous avez déjà répondu à
certaines questions parce que Stéphan
Deidi m'a demandé la parole et il a dit
qu'il avait eu la réponse à sa question
moi j'ai cinq demandes de
parole j'en ai un peu plus je crois que
j'en ai une dizaine d'accord on a 30
minutes et puis on a 30 minutes euh donc
je vais donner la parole à Monsieur
Fanen merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président de l'ASN euh
remercie pour ces premiers propos et ses
premiers éclaircissements ma première
interrogation porte sur le risque de
désorganisation euh qui serait fortement
préjudiciable à la création de cette
nouvelle entité si d'aventure elle
devait voir le jour au moment où la
filière électronucléaire on aurait le
plus besoin vous l'avez évoqué dans vos
propos le P le pic d'activité
interviendra d'ici 2027 2028 nous avons
toutes et tous en tête l'opposition du
personnel notamment de RSN à ce projet
de fusion avec le risque mis en lumière
par le rapporteur Pascal Martin d'une
fite aussi de compétence au moment aussi
où il faudra bien au contraire en
accumuler d'autres au sein de la
nouvelle entité et aujourd'hui le risque
est à mes yeux en tout cas bien trop
important au regard du fonctionnement
qui a déjà fait ses preuves de ce
système dual et nous pouvons regretter
que dans le rapport qui a été mené par
l'OPEX et bien c'est le scénario de la
fusion qui est présidé à tous les débats
et non pas celui de l'approfondissement
et du renforcement de ce modèle pour
lequel d'ailleurs les deux entités
avaient déjà été force de proposition il
y a quelques années et parl d'une voie
commune pour le renforcer ma deuxième
interrogation elle porte sur
l'acceptation il en a été question c'est
le parlementaire du département
certainement le plus nucléarisé de
France qui vous interroge à ce sujet
puisque dans le département de la Manche
et plus encore dans la presquile du
côentin nous avons trois entités trois
sites nucléaires concentrés sur un
périmètre géographique éminemment
restreint une usine de production
centrale de production celle de DF et
qui verra le réacteur de le Pr bientôt
être mis en service une usine de
retraitement C d'oranolag et évidemment
le site historique de naval group de
l'ancienne DCN où sont fabriqués les
sous-marins nucléaires et il existe
trois CLIS sur ce territoire et nous
devons avoir à l'esprit évidemment la
mise en garde faite par l'ANCLI à
l'égard de ce projet de fusion et le
risque au moment où la filière est
appelée à être relancée et aussi à
opérer une mutation considérable avec et
vous l'avez vous-même évoqué la création
des smmr qui vont être bien plus diffus
sur notre territoire et qui rejoint une
question éminemment importante
d'aménagement du territoire et de notre
politique énergétique et bien voir nos
concitoyens être particulièrement
inquiets si d'aventure le système de
contrôle d'expertise et de régulation
été appelé à être affaibli et ma
question donc sera de savoir si à vos
yeux quels sont les véritables avantages
comparatifs aujourd'hui entre ce projet
de fusion tel qu'il est imaginé dans
l'avant projet de loi et celui d'un
approfondissement de ce système dual qui
malheureusement n'a pas été à nos yeux
assez expertisé et si d'aventure
approfondissement de ce système dual il
devait y avoir serait-il toujours
opportun de maintenir ce projet de
fusion je vous
remercie
éeline Renaud
garabédien merci Madame présidente
monsieur le Président le gouvernement
souhaite que la fusion si elle est votée
bien entendu puisse entrer en vigueur en
2025 tout le monde sait qu'un
rapprochement entraîne des contraintes
de réorganisation de tout type
informatique social commercial
communication en en rendant le coût
totalement exorbitant notamment par la
prolongation des délais j'aurais deux
questions à vous poser monsieur le
président
en combien de temps est-ce que vous
pensez que cette fusion pourra être
réalisée et est-ce que les bénéfices
prévisionnels qui sont escomtés vont
être largement compensé par les dépenses
qui en tout état de cause vont être
beaucoup plus importantes que celles qui
sont initialement prévu merci de votre
réponse alors je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur
Devinaz merci monsieur le président
j'avais une question sur la transparence
mais comme elle a été posée par notre
rapporteur Pascal Martin je reviens pas
dessus monsieur le Président vous avez
souligné que les ces deux organismes sur
le plan international sont reconnus pour
leur expertise et pour la sûreté
nucléaire du reste la Cour des comptes a
souligné l'efficacité de ce système dual
et vous comprendrez que on est en droit
de s'interroger sur la concomitance de
la relance du nucléaire et de cette
réforme hier au soir en écoutant le
président de la République je me suis
demander si cette réforme ne
s'inscrivait pas dans le triptique qu'il
a souhaité rappeler faire plus vite
faire moins cher faire mieux et d'où ma
question est-ce que cette orientation
est-elle le meilleur moyen de
renforcer le binôme sur
et sécurité
nucléaire Amel
gaker merci madame la présidente
monsieur le Président je vais tout
d'abord revenir donc la relance de la
filière nucléaire va forcément pose
forcément la question de la Sûreté
Nucléaire un sujet particulièrement
sensible pour notre population ce qui
conditionne l'acceptabilité qui va
conditionner l'acceptabilité des
nouveaux projets de construction de PA
annoncé je reviens sur la période de
trouble je vais la qualifier en fait
ainsi connu l'année dernière à l'annonce
de la fusion des deux entités fusion qui
je le rappelle avait déjà été évoqué par
d'autres
gouvernements des oppositions internes
aux structures ont été exprimées cette
annonce a élu concrètement un impact sur
vos structures en matière de ressources
humaines notamment le départ de
personnel depuis cette première annonce
vous évoquez une condition de réussite
ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises hein
face à la montée en puissance en ex
expertise mais aussi en volume de
travail est-ce que vous avez d'ors et
déjà des garanties une garantie sur le
renforcement des moyens et des
compétences si la fusion devait être
réalisée et enfin concernant le projet
de loi relatif à l'organisation de la
gouvernance dont il est question
aujourd'hui avez-vous connaissance d'une
étude d'impact réalisée étude d'impact
qui nous est très cher ici
particulièrement au sein de de notre
assemblée et puis enfin pourriez-vous
nous préciser la façon dont vous avez
été associé à la préparation de cette de
C de ce projet de loi je vous
remercie la parole est à renaand Dantec
oui merci monsieur le Président je crois
que quand on s'occupe de de risqu avec
Pascal Martin on a tous les deux eu des
responsabilités de collectivité il y a
un point qui est extrêmement important
c'est de penser en dehors de la boîte
out of the box comme on dit en bon
français c'est-à-dire qu'il faut qu'on
garde des gens qui réfléchissent et se
posent des questions que personne ne se
pose
et ce qui veut dire donc ma question est
est-ce que parce que on entend bien
qu'il va y avoir énormément de boulot
que donc la SN va se retourner vers le
collège d'experts exirsn avec beaucoup
de demandes ce qui pourrait saturer
totalement la capacité de recherche et
de réflexion de l'exirsn on va l'appeler
collège d'expertise pour pour l'instant
donc quels sont
aujourd'hui les garanties que vous
apportez sur la sûreté je vous rejoint
sur la sécurité je pense
qu'effectivement je vous rejoins tout à
fait faut certainement pas découpler les
deux pour que ce collège d'expert
finalement en toute indépendance puisse
se poser des questions y compris ne se
pose pas la partie ASN ça c'est un point
extrêmement important parce que vous
avez cité l'exemple américain où
effectivement on est sur une structure
intégrée
mais nous avons aux États-Unis beaucoup
de de labos de grandes universités qui
travaillent aussi de manière
indépendante sur les mêmes questions ce
qui permet de de de maintenir ce cet
échange voir cette friction sur des
questions qui ne sont pas au au cœur
finalement de ce que vous pourriez vous
définir comme prioritaire donc ma
question j'en poserai pas d'autrre il y
a la question de la transparence et qui
qui est au cœur mais on on on reparlera
d'autres moment donc comment
maintenez-vous cette capacité de penser
à des choses auxquelles de personne n'a
pensé soit en interne où est-ce que pour
justement y compris en terme finalement
ça a été posé comme question juste pour
pour la confiance de la population
est-ce qu'on cherche aussi finalement à
mobiliser des labos en dehors de la
nouvelle entité pour continuer de se
poser des questions que personne ne se
pose alors à côté le voisin Daniel Salm
merci madame la Présidente Messieurs les
Présidents l'objectif affiché est de
fluidifier de simplifier est-ce que on
va pas aboutir exactement à l'inverse
avec C cette association de de cultures
qui sont très différentes vous avez
d'ailleurs parlé de priorités
différentes tout à l'heure j'aimerais
bien que vous nous donniez des
précisions sur ces priorités différentes
entre l'IRSN et l'ASN parce que on
risque de perdre ses cette différence et
je pense qu'elle est essentielle donc
avec ces deux cultures est-ce qu'on va
pas avoir une internalisation des
tensions qui sont déjà existantes mais
qui peuvent se cristalliser dans une
même structure et donc être source de de
perturbation je pense que aujourd'hui on
on fonctionne non pas seulement avec une
balité mais avec un un triptique avec
l'exploitant RSN et la SN qui permet
d'avoir toujours un tiers qui peut
observer les deux autres et on a entendu
que c'était quelque chose de très très
important pour notre sûreté donc voilà
merci la parole est à Martha de Sidrac
merci président euh je vous remercie
pour toute votre intervention monsieur
le Président vous nous avez vanté aussi
effectivement votre capacité à
travailler en bonne intelligence avec
l'IRSN la qualité de ces deux entités a
été rappelée par tous les collègues qui
se sont déjà exprimés euh euh vous
sembliez dire également que de toute
façon quoi qu'il en soit si cette fusion
doit avoir lieu il va falloir dans la
loi inscrire la séparation entre la
partie décisionnelle et la partie
expertise donc en réalité moi je me pose
encore la question de savoir quel
intérêt aujourd'hui véritablement de
fusionner d'autant plus que dans vos
propos liminires vous avez aussi
expliquer que au regard de cette charge
qui monte pour un tas un tas de raisons
il va falloir de toute façon dans cette
future entité faire appel aussi à de
l'expertise externe donc comment la
voyez-vous cette expertise externe d'où
proviendrait-elle et quelle sera en
réalité la
capacité dans ce moment crucial pour la
France de de pouvoir gérer tout ce qui
doit être géré à la fois pour le parc
vieillissant et pour le parc futur
puisque cela a été rappelé également par
un de mes collègues nous allons
traverser une période de turbulence le
temps que cette nouvelle entité se mette
correctement en place je vous remercie
alors la voisine de Mara la présidente
prima merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le le président merci
effectivement vos propos moi j'aurais
peut-être deux petites questions pratico
pratiqu on va prendre le cas de la
corrosion sous contrainte qu'est-ce qui
aurait été
différent si nous avions déjà cette
future entité
probable qu'est-ce qui aurait été plus
vite est-ce que le problème aurait été
détecté de la même façon est-ce que les
solutions aurait été les mêmes est-ce
que la sécurité aurait été la même et la
sûreté aurait été assurée de la même
façon sur un cas pratique qui est ce
problème de corrosion sous contrainte
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
qui pour vous et pour EDF d'ailleurs et
donc pour la sûrté de nos concitoyens
aurait été mieux en fait en réalité la
deuxème c'est que vous avez deuxè
question à rapport à au
militaire et à la liaison il y a
évidemment des compétences chez vos
ingénieurs et c'est les ingénieurs qui
qui qui s'évissent si j'ose dire dans le
militaire des des critères d'excellence
qui sont les mêmes et des critères de
compéten qui sont les mêmes il y a
vraiment une séparation parce que je si
je prends le secteur de l'aérospatial
aujourd'hui il y a des compétences qui
sont utilisées à la fois dans le
militaire et dans le civil est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas là aussi
de la compétence croisée à faire entre
ces deux
secteurs merci je vais donner la parole
à NAD Javet puis j'en aurais terminé
pour les demandes de parole pour la
commission si d'autres ont envie de
merci monsieur le Président on parlait
compéten donc je continue sur cette même
thématique vous avez parlé de 100000
postes sur 10 ans donc 10000 par an
est-ce que on connaît tous les
problématiques de recrutement dans C un
secteur aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
déjà identifié les compétences rares qui
nous manquent et l'offre de formation
qu'elle soit en alternance ou continue
sera-t-elle suffisante pour atteindre
les objectifs en matière de RH je vous
remercie alors je vais terminer avec
quatre prises de parole pour la
commission des affaires économiques
Fabien Guay
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président bon vous nous présentez la
le projet de fusion sous un beau jour ce
qui est évidemment très bien
suivant la position où vous êtes mais on
sait la réalité pourquoi ce projet de
fusion est forcé parce que il y a une
volonté politique du gouvernement de
relancer très rapidement le nucléaire on
a eu un projet de loi d'ailleurs pour
accélérer un certain nombre de choses
dont nous d'ailleurs nous avons soulevé
un certain nombre de questions notamment
sur les questions de transparen
et qui n'est pas que des simplifications
administratives parce que de toute façon
nous tant communiste on a toujours été
pour le nucléaire à deux conditions un
haut statut pour les salariés et la
transparence pour les populations et
donc sur ce biais là on ne peut pas on
ne peut pas s'en passer et la deuxième
chose c'est que en réalité dans le
tripticque
EDF ou exploitant ASN RSN on a toujours
considéré vous avez toujours considéré
que les RSN était un caillou dans la
chaussure et que prenait des expertises
sans la question industrielle et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on va faire ce projet
de fusion pour essayer justement
d'accélérer c'est ça la volonté et la
dernière chose c'est la rationalité
économique efficience même si elle en
réalité elle va être bien plus complexe
moi je passe sur les questions de
transparence même si on aura le temps
d'y revenir dans le débat parlementaire
parce que pour vous pour laasn il y a
des choses qui vont plutôt dans le bon
sens mais par contre sur l'IRSN dont les
avis et les sont rendus public depuis
2015 je pense qu'il y aura un certain
nombre de recul moi j'en viens sur la
question des salariés il y a des
craintes du côté de l'IRSN mais aussi
chez vous ce qui est normal parce que
c'est plutôt les votes d'ailleurs qui
sont sur contrat de droit public qui
sont des fonctionnaires les autres lirsn
étant plutôt en contrat de droit privé
d'ailleurs ni les uns ni les autres ne
veulent changer statut mais on sait très
bien que dans une fusion la réalité
c'est que c'est plutôt le droit privé
qui pourrait prendre le pas dans
quelques années sur les fonctionnaires
et donc sur les fonctionnaires de l'ASN
donc c'est une question et dernière je
reviens je crois que c'est une ou deux
collègues qui ont posé la question
est-ce que vous êtes sûr et certain que
vous allez être prêt au 1er janvier
2025 par exemple il y a 12 groupes de
travail je sais qu'il travaillent sur la
fusion j'en prends un sur les questions
informatiques vous avez 50 logiciels
l'IRSN aujourd'hui 400 et quand on
interroge les salariés qui connaissent
bien mieux le métier que moi et qui sont
au turbain tous les jours ils vous
disent que en une année ça sera
impossible de tout mettre à l'ordre du
jour donc là vous voyez et puis a une
dernière je le
fais il va avoir des fortes question
sociale dans la future autorité et le
problème c'est qu'ils sont en train de
négocier avec vous et demain et vous
l'avez dit votre mandat va arriver quel
quel va être en
réalité sur quoi ils vont pouvoir
s'appuyer sachant que les promesses qui
sont faites aujourd'hui ne seront plus
par les hommes de demain et donc là il y
a des vrais véritable question et on
pourra pas tout renvoyer à la
négociation sans que le législateur et
son Moot à dire je je le dis aussi dans
le débat législatif je vous remercie
merci Fabien Daniel gremiller
oui merci présidente monsieur le
Président le Sénat en 2023 avait déjà
mis un certain nombre de
avait alerté sur l'aspect sécurité
et sûreté avec le le climat la cyber et
cetera aujourd'hui vous l'avez
évoqué on va vers nouvelle génération de
nouvelles générations nucléire 4e
génération le principal interlocuteur
jusqu'à présent était EDF demain ça sera
plus que il y aura d'autres
interlocuteurs donc ça va être un peu
plus complexe
pensez-vous que le texte tel qu'il est
rédigé permet apporter à la fois
sécurité et sûreté sur ce nouveau
nucléaire il y a le côté humain côté
humain on tombe mal on est dans un
contexte international où tout le monde
relance nucléaire est-ce que cette ce
projet de fusion et peut-être pour faire
face à l'absence effectivement de
capacité de trouver les femmes et les
hommes qui vont être N ser c'est une
question parce qu'aujourd'hui je suis
pas sûr qu'on aura sur la scène
internationale euh les femmes et les
hommes dont nous avons
besoin une question sur la recherche
aujourd'hui la recherche quand on est on
est sur nucléaire elle touche à la fois
l'énergie elle touche le militaire elle
touche la
santé est-ce que le texte tel qu'il est
n'appauvrit pas ce domaine de recherche
euh pour le futur et enfin dernier point
ce texte il doit être vivant on est
parti sur des investissements très
lourds il nous faut gérer à la fois la
prolongation la fin de vie des centrales
et puis toutes ces nouvelles générations
de nucléaire est-ce que ne pensez-vous
pas qu'il serait nécessaire que certains
articles puissent être des avant des
avenants possibles pour rendre vivant
dans le temps ce texte de fusion et de
mission de la future
asnr Franck monteer
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le le président euh je voudrais
aborder de de deux points euh le
rapporteur Pascal Martin a évoqué en
priorité la question de de l'humain à
l'écoute des des des personnels de
l'IRSN en particulier il semblerait
qu'il a des des départs euh un nombre
important de personnel de de de haut
niveau donc qui feront forcément défaut
dans la dans la future configuration
qu'elle soit celle de la fusion ou ou ou
ou pas est-ce que vous confirmez cela et
et et qué-il mis en en place pour Ben
retenir autant que que faire ce peut
parce que c'est nécessaire les
personnels les personnel concerné
deuxième point qui n'a pas du tout été
abordé ce matin me semble-t-il
la question des moyens des moyens euh à
court terme mais à moyen terme compte
tenu du du programme de travail qui se
qui se profile notamment avec le le
nouveau nucléaire la loi de finances
2024 prévoit des des augmentations
budgétaires mais répondant je dirais à
au cadre
organisationnel actuel
euh je n'ai pas su voir dans l'étude de
impact les perspectives budgétaires euh
pour les années à venir euh la
planification budgétaire la
programmation budgétaire lié à cette
réforme ou ce projet de réforme
important qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire est tant entendu que je
comprends mais j'en doute que l'objectif
de faire des économies globalement n'est
pas
priorisé ou exposé en tout cas en tant
que tel à ce stade voilà
euh merci pour pour votre réponse alors
dernière question Bernard buit merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président une récente tribune dans le
journal Le Monde s'inquiète que le
projet de fusion serait contraire aux
objectifs de sûreté et de maintien de la
confiance car il conduirait à mettre fin
à l'indépendance de l'expertise par
rapport à la prise de décision en
matière de sûreté nucléaire indépendance
actuellement assuré outre l'existence de
deux structures distinctes par une
disposition légale prescrivant la
publicité des avis de l'IRSN les avis
resteront-ils
public voilà monsieur le Président donc
on a bien conscience que ça va vous être
très difficile de répondre l'ensemble de
ces questions d'utant plus qu'on va
avoir l'audition de Monsieur Niel dans
quelques instants et peut-être vous
pouvez un petit peu synthétiser et
apporter quand même quelques élément
combien de temps exactement écoutez
l'audition est prévue à 11h on peut un
petit peu déborder mais pas pas trop non
plus minut 10 minutes bien ben écoutez
merci beaucoup pour toutes ces questions
bon tout d'abord je je tiens à rappeler
que je suis le président de l'Autorité
de seté nucléaire et que c'est un projet
qui est présenté par le gouvernement il
y a un certain nombre de questions que
vous avez posé que je trouve tout à fait
légitime et je pense qu'ell serait tout
à fait légitime à être posé au
gouvernement qui est à l'initiative de
ce projet et et qui a préparé non
seulement le texte mais qui a aussi
élaboré l'étude d'impact vous avez posé
un certain nombre de questions et donc
il m'est difficile de me substituer au
gouvernement en tant que président d'une
autorité indépendante du gouvernement
est-ce que la la réforme si elle était
décidée créerait une un risque de
désorganisation mais oui je ne connais
pas de réforme et en plus de réforme de
cette nature qui ne comporte pas au
démarrage au moins un risque de
difficulté c'est inérant à la réforme
faut-il ne jamais réformer au motif
qu'une réforme crée des
dysfonctionnements c'est à vous de
décider mais je pense qu'il faut y
réfléchir nous sommes face à un enjeu je
l'ai dit dans mon introduction qui est
tout à fait inédit est-ce que
l'organisation actuelle pourrait faire
face vous avez dit que il faudrait
peut-être comparer la manière de faire
évoluer l'organisation actuelle
indépendamment de l'idée de fusionner je
crois que c'est dans l'étude d'impact
c'est au gouvernement de répondre à
cette question en terme de comparaison
de d'un choix qui aurait été possible en
revanche je dis que face aux enjeux
auxquels nous nous trouvons qui sont
vraiment inédits depuis 50 ans on ne
pourra pas faire face si on maintient
l'organisation exactement telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui ça c'est pas possible ça
c'est ça trop frictionnel il y a trop de
complexité ce n'est pas possible et nous
sommes à des enjeux qui sont nouveaux ça
a été je citerai pas les les les bien
évidment les questions qui ont été
posées en tout cas ceux qui les ont posé
mais c'est tout à fait juste que nous
sommes et également devant un contexte
un environnement qui n'a rien à voir
avec celui que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un système
que nous pouvons qualifier de 3 x un il
y a un un seul exploitant nucléaire il a
une seule technologie les réacteurs à ha
spression il a qu'un seul usage il
produit l'électricité nous sommes
aujourd'hui en contact avec plus d'une
quinzaine de start-up qui portent des
projets de nouveau nucléaair des SMR des
Amr des petits réacteurs il n'y a qu'à
travers cette diffusion de nouveaux
réacteurs bien évidment si elle est
acceptée qu'il pourra y avoir une
véritable décarbonation de l'industrie
pour pouvoir non pas produire de
l'électricité mais de la chaleur qui est
de la chaleur dans les usages
industriels avec des tout petits
réacteurs c'est quelques mgaw par
rapport à un PR qui fait 1650 MW bien
sûr il y a plein de questions qui se
posent en matière de sécurité sûreté
j'ai dit de manière intégrée il faut le
faire il y a les questions de
l'acceptabilité d'avoir des
microéacteurs qui sont plutôt diffus
mais les modes d'instruc de ces projets
n'ont plus rien à voir avec ceux que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui nous avons
que quatre grands exploitants nucléaires
aujourd'hui EDF Orano le CEA et l'endra
nous avons du temps nous avons des gens
que nous connaissons qui ont une
expertise demain c'est pas du tout ça
nous avons des gens qui qui qui sont
extrêmement agiles d'ailleurs hein il
faut dire qu'ils sont très agiles ils
développent des concept qui n'existe pas
sur lesquels parfois on a même pas
d'expérience il y a quatre projets de
SMR qui sont très très développé il il y
en a qu'un seul qui est à récteur à haut
souspression trois technologies que nous
ne maîtrisons pas totalement il va
falloir investir devant de nouvelles
compétences vous croyez qu'il va on va
trouver des compétences sur ces trois
réacteurs nouveaux même d'autres en en
mettant à l'IRSN et à laasn parce qu'il
va falloir que quelqu'un fasse
l'expertise sur cette nouvelle
technologie et quelqu'un qui évalue le
résultat de l'expertise l'efficacité
c'est d'avoir qu'une seule ressource qui
est rare qui sera difficile à recruter
on dit il y a des personnes qui partent
de l'IRSN aujourd'hui c'est vrai il y a
des gens qui partent de l'IRSN mais
d'abord il faut regarder le nombre de
gens qui partent hein c'est pas des
fuites en avant il y a un nombre plus
important de départ qu'auparavant et ce
sont des gens qui se sont vu proposer
des conditions salariales dans les
exemples qui m'ont été donnés qui n'ont
rien à voir avec la situation
d'aujourd'hui certains ont vu des
propositions d'augmentation de salire de
90 %. un un expert de l'IRSN s vous
proposer de de reprendre sa charge de
prêt immobilier de 200000 € qu'il avait
qui le demande ce sont les gens de la
filière nucléaire les start-upers qui
veulent des compétences on n'a pas ces
compétences aujourd'hui en France pour
pouvoir développer leur projets et nous
leur leur demandons nous leur disons
vous avez besoin de démontrer votre
capacité technique et financière à être
de futur exploitant et ben il recrutent
il recrutent et il recrutent à l'IRSN là
où il y a des expertises c'est pas lié
au projet de fusion on explique que oui
c'est la fusion qui crée non non non les
conditions de marché du travail dans la
sreté nucléaire sont t qu'aujourd'hui on
chasse les experts de l'IRSN et ça c'est
ça arrivera quelle que soit la solution
que vous choisirez de retenir parce que
il y a un problème de ressources rares
qui nous concerne bien évidemment
également j'ai vous avez évoqué
plusieurs questions sur la recherche je
n'ai pas répondu à la question
précédente sur la recherche bien évident
que la recherche elle est absolument
indispensable notamment en terme de lien
entre la recherche et l'expertise et une
autorité future devra avoir une ambition
pour la recherche et je suis convaincu
que la future ASLR aura une ambition
forte pour la recherche et que les
partenariats de recherche y compris avec
lesexatant devront être
préservés et on ne peut pas imaginer
d'avoir effectivement une vision sur les
enjeux de sûreté si on n pas on n'est
pas adossé à une capacité d'anticipation
de ces enjeux qui repose notamment sur
la recherche et y compris la recherche
partenariale donc il faudra avoir une
ambition forte pour la recherche et il
faudra avoir une ambition forte qui sera
adossée à des contrats avec bien sûr des
des partenaires étrangers et des
partenaires industriels la loi prévoit
un certain nombre de dispositions en
matière de reconnaissance de la future
autorité en tant qu'organisme de
recherche il y a eu vraiment un examen
en profondeur de toutes les dispositions
qu'il fallait introduire pour par la loi
pour qu'il n'y ait aucun frein au
maintien de la capacité de recherche
actuelle de l'IRSN dans la future
structure tant en terme de cherche de
recrutement de chercheurs de Tesar de
reconnaissance de la future entité de
recherche de l'autorité au niveau
international l'évaluation HCS tout ceci
est dans le projet de loi et donc il y a
eu une précaution particulière pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de perte de la
recherche la recherche est bien celle
qui va éclairer les enjeux de
l'expertise pour le futur le fait
d'avoir dans une même autorité une
capacité de recherche d'expertise de
mesure des effets dans l'environnement
sera une force par rapport aux enjeux du
réchauffement climatique aujourd'hui
nous avons nous la responsabilité de la
prescription des conditions de
prélèvement d'eau et de rejet par
exemple nous avons des moyens de mesure
dans l'environnement bien sûr de ce qui
se passe envers Roget et l'IRSN a une
Capac nous avons une capacité
d'expertise interne l'IRSN a une
capacité d'expertise et elleelle a des
moyens de recherche dans le domaine du
réchauffement climatique toute cet
ensemble là sur la totalité de la chaîne
de l'analyse prospective des enjeux et
des impacts du réchaufement climatique
jusqu'à sa traduction dans les
dispositions réglementair qui
s'imposeront aux exploitants bah tout ça
sera dans une même chaîne de
commandement et de décision je pense que
c'est important ça peut être une force
pour la la future
autorité je n'ai pas parlé de de de
sujet lié au au alors il y a beaucoup de
sujets concernant les salariés hein je
je les salariés il y a aussi dans les
dans le projet de loi toute une série de
dispositions vous l'avez vu pour
maintenir la totalité des statuts qui
existent c'est vrai qu'il y a des
statuts de droit privé au sein des IRSN
et il y a des statuts de droit public au
sein de laasn le projet de loi et ça ça
a été un des sujets tout à l'heure
m'était demandé est-ce que nous avons
été associés au projet oui on a été
associé à l'élaboration du projet et
c'est un point sur lequel on a beaucoup
insisté pour conserver la diversité des
statuts dans la future autorité non
seulement à sa création mais également
dans son fonctionnement futur pour
pouvoir recruter dans tous les statuts
c'est une richesse pour la future
autorité c'est pas un risque de
substitution c'est une richesse parce
que pour pouvoir avoir des chercheurs
c'est pas forcément des chercheurs qui
son qui ont un statut particulier il
faut balayer la totalité des statuts il
faut préserver les statuts publics comme
préserver les statuts privés le le texte
de loi le prévoit et je pense que c'est
une force dans la future autorité et et
donc c'est un élément qui me paraît
répondre aux objections qui ont été
formulées en ce qui concerne les statuts
est-ce que ça va complexifier le
fonctionnement mais bien évidemment avec
toutes ces diversité de statut ça va
être compliqué mais si on s'arrête à
chaque fois que c'est compliqué c'est
plus la peine si vous voulez aujourd'hui
on a déjà des statuts qui sont divers au
sein de la l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire on a déjà des associations
avec différents publics on a des
fonctionnaires mais on a aussi des
personnes qui sont de statut privés et
qui sont mis à disposition au sein de la
SCN et d'ailleurs il y a ces statuts
privés mis à disposition de la RSN
comporte une bonne partie qui sont des
gens de l'IRSN c'est faux c'est faux de
dire qu'il y a des cultures différentes
il y a des fonctionnement croiser des
échanges des personnels de l'IRSN qui
viennent travailler 3 ans à laasn qui
repartent à l'IRSN et et réciproquement
on a le la le même type de
fonctionnement et le même type
d'approche sur les sujets donc je je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'arguments que
j'ai entendu ici je terminerai là-dessus
parce que je vois que nous sommes pris
et je serais vraiment ravi de répondre à
vos questions à vos autres questions
éventuellement dans un autre cadre mais
il y a beaucoup de sujets qui sont mis
en avant qui ont il faut le dire d'une
certaine manière plutôt vocation à vous
effrayer je je pense qu'il faut être
réaliste par rapport à ça et et et et je
suis absolument convaincu que bien
évidemment il faut écouter les gens il
faut intégrer ces ces appréhensions ou
ses craintes et il faut trouver des
solutions mais par rapport à la à ce
dont nous avons besoin c'est-à-dire à la
mettre la mise en place d'un système qui
soit efficace un système qui ne Brat pas
le niveau de sûreté c'est pas ça la
question la question c'est de supprimer
un certain nombre de points de faiblesse
que nous avons aujourd'hui j'ai parlé
des doublons j'ai parlé de la friction
dans le fonctionnement j'ai parlé de la
divergence qui peut peut exister entre
deux entités séparées qui peuvent avoir
des options différentes en matière de de
pilotage en matière de
priorité mais c'est la vie c'est la vie
si on veut éviter ça il faut
effectivement avoir une certaine unité
une une entité resserrée et c'est pas
parce qu'il y a une entité resserré
qu'on brade le niveau
d'exigence c'est une peur on a met en en
place j'ai vu les tribunes comme vous on
met en avant toute une série de peurs le
système va s'effondrer dans les 10 à 15
ans s'il y a une fusion qui qui le crois
vraiment c'est une peur ça n'a aucun
sens voilà ce que je voulais dire
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente je suis conscient que je n'ai
pas répondu à l'ensemble de vos
questions mais je suis à votre
disposition pour aller plus loin merci
monsieur le Président pe-être pas
répondu à toutes les questions mais vous
avez quand même apporté des précisions
importantes à nos deux commissions voilà
je laisse le soin à ma collègue si elle
veut conclure merci non je je m'associe
à au remerciement du Président ljau vous
avez été
fort fort complet d'ors et déjà et je
crois que vous avez permis de satisfaire
un certain nombre de nos collègues qui
se posaient des questions tout à fait
légitime merci beaucoup à vous merci
Monsieur le Directeur
merci
bien mes chers